Bad medical advice? Rich, neglectful
parents? "CoComelon" has a lot more
going on under the surface than children realize!
Although many kids excitedly shriek
"CoComelon" at the screen every time
they see those two front teeth and that single
blonde swirl, "CoComelon" is actually the name
of the YouTube Channel and streaming
show. The kids are on the right track,
as the blonde baby is the main character and
his face has become synonymous with the show,
but hordes of toddlers around the world have been
surprised to learn that his name is actually JJ.
The confusion is completely warranted
considering the titles of many popular
kids' shows are simply the name of the main
character. "Bluey," "Peppa Pig," "Winnie the
Pooh," "Daniel Tiger's Neighborhood,"
and "Arthur" are just a few examples.
JJ, his Mommy, Daddy, his sister YoYo, his
brother TomTom, and a slew of other friends,
family, and animals collectively make
up the world of "CoComelon." Granted,
many parents are confused by this as well,
but the fact that multiple videos that only
featured animals were also titled "CoComelon"
became the dead giveaway. Questions about the
name were raised and ultimately answered with
songs like "The Potty Training Song," where
the family specifically says, "Great job, JJ!"
Then, of course, there's the "JJ song" itself.
This one seems to affect parents in a big way.
Throughout the entire "CoComelon" catalog,
JJ displays the broadest spectrum of cognitive
abilities. While enjoying the show, it would
be near impossible for toddlers to pick up on
the timing of developmental stages. However,
parents are increasingly more aware of the
many leaps their children should be making
around certain ages. The Huffington Post
gathered numerous parental tweets about
"Cocomelon," and many call out JJ's
extraordinary abilities in a big way.
JJ's actual age has been estimated at anywhere
from 1 to 4 years old. But in some cases,
his intelligence would place him lower than a 1
year old, and in others, a lot higher than the
average 4 year old. In the episode "Baby Bump,"
JJ and his best friend Cody act as detectives,
and uncover clues like a rattle, a pacifier, and a
baby bottle to come to the conclusion that Cody's
mom must be pregnant. In the episode "Humpty
Dumpty," JJ giggles and babbles like a baby,
but also engineers a parachute for
an egg in an egg drop experiment.
Mommy and Daddy's income is hopefully
something that a show's younger viewers
don't have to think about. Even so, after
scoping the family's house and the laundry
list of fun activities they're able to do with
the kids, more than a few older viewers have
started wondering how JJ's parents are
able to afford their lavish lifestyle.
Parents in the audience have discussed the
house itself, since the color, furniture,
and overall layout of each room changes song to
song. In the parents version of the song "Johny
Johny Yes Papa," the parents are seen in a quaint
kitchen with pictures of vegetables decorating
the walls. But in "Pat A Cake 2," the family
walks into a bright yellow beehive kitchen. The
initial version of "Johny Johny Yes Papa" shows a
third version of their kitchen, which raises the
question, "Is this family that well-off, or are
they good friends with Chip and Joanna Gaines?"
"Took it out 100%. Zero breaks."
"This is nice."
With childcare at the forefront of any parent's
mind, even the cost of JJ's pristine preschool,
the Melon Patch Academy, has been
called into question. Not that JJ's
parents need to explain themselves,
but their jobs are never mentioned,
and they always seem to have ample
time off to play with the kids.
Judging other parents' child rearing? Now
that's something every parent can get behind.
"Oh! You are not telling
me how to raise my child."
"You do not tell this woman
how to raise her child."
"You do not tell her how to raise me."
Kids definitely wouldn't notice
this, and even if they did,
they'd most likely be a little jealous
of JJ and his siblings' freedom. With the
children being left unattended, bouncing
around town without parental supervision,
it's easy for any parent to wonder about the
lackadaisical rules in this family's household.
The "Car Wash Song" video, for example, suggests
that a preschool trio can wash a car unattended.
The whole thing will strike any parent viewing as
even more irresponsible when they notice that the
kids are doing this only steps away from a
busy road with double solid yellow lines.
On a similar note, in the "Breakfast
Song," the children concoct giant,
unhealthy breakfasts consisting entirely of
pancakes, syrup, waffles, whipped cream, bacon,
ham, and white bread with jam. It's all fried up
on a hot stove with zero parental supervision.
Many of the things only parents notice about
"CoComelon" are nitpicks within the world of
the show, but they aren't all bad. For example,
there's the "CoComelon" rendition of the classic
song "Pat-A-Cake," which has educated many parents
who grew up singing it as "Patty Cake." Of course,
other kids and parents may have only ever
known the song as "Pat-A-Cake." But for
those who've been singing "Patty Cake"
all along, you can take comfort in the
fact that this pronunciation is very
common, and widely accepted as well.
"Pat-A-Cake" versus "Patty Cake" has been debated
for decades. But experts like Sunn m'Cheaux — a
Gullah language teacher from Harvard University
— claim that "Pat-a" was pronounced "Patty" in
different languages and dialects. As long
as the cake makers in question mold it,
pat it, and mark it with a B, it seems
both pronunciations have some merit.
"CoComelon" has served up fresh
renditions of a lot of nursery rhymes,
some of which they've opted to put their own
unique spin on. When children like a song,
they don't question its origins. However, parents
tuning into "CoComelon" will be likely to notice
distinct similarities with songs that they, their
parents, and even their grandparents grew up with.
"Winter Show and Tell at School" is sung to
the tune of "On the First Day of Christmas."
"Bath Song" is the most popular video on
the "CoComelon" channel with nearly 5.8
billion views. While it has original
lyrics, the verse is sung to the tune
of "Itsy Bitsy Spider" and the chorus
has the same melody as "Baby Shark."
Children's songs performed to the tune
of classic nursery rhymes are actually
quite common. Some of our most well-known
nursery rhymes, like "ABC," "Twinkle Twinkle
Little Star," and "Baa Baa Black Sheep" are
actually all sung in the same tune and tempo.
These songs and some variations composed by
Mozart all share the common ancestor of a
hit 1740 French folk song. Much like a movie
or TV character watching a movie or TV show
from several decades ago, current children's
songs that use classic nursery rhymes are more
often than not doing so to avoid copyright
infringement. Not to mention the fact that
it helps a new song's chances of success.
The classics are classics for a reason.
While your child blankly stares at the
screen with their jaw on the floor,
you can rest assured they're not counting the
seconds of each shot. For parents who are trying
to find the proper balance between entertaining
their children and melting their brains,
the pace of a show has become very important.
There is no shortage of new shows vying for
the attention of young viewers, but when parents
and experts are asked if "CoComelon" specifically
is safe or hyper-stimulating for children, the
answers seem to be split right down the middle.
For comparison, a TikTok user clocked "My Little
Pony" shots as lasting 4 to 6 seconds each. Each
"CoComelon" shot, on the other hand, only
lasts 1 to 3 seconds in length. This video,
as well as a follow-up video showing
that nearly every "CoComelon" shot
either zooms in or out or pans side to side,
inspired over 300 parents to weigh in on the
"Parenting" Subreddit. Many commented that
their children watched the show obsessively,
and would become unusually upset after
it was turned off. Dr. Rebecca G. Cowan,
a professor of social and behavioral sciences
at Walden University, told Parenting.com,
"Without empirical research on
the show 'CoComelon,' there is
no data to substantiate claims that this show is
overstimulating due to the pace of the scenes."
It seems that until more structured
research is performed, it will be up
to parents whether or not it's healthy
for their children to view the show. .
For the average young viewer, it's unlikely that
children will pick up on the subtle nuances of
a couple's relationship in a TV show or YouTube
video. After watching the video for the parents'
version of "Johny Johny Yes Papa," it isn't
hard for any adult viewer to pick up on the
sneaking around, the distrust, the judgment,
and the outright lying present in the clip.
The video opens on the father sneaking into the
kitchen in the middle of the night for a slice
of pizza. The mother then flicks on the light and
judges him as if he's straying from their strict
diet. The father then catches and judges her for
enjoying some ice cream. It gets a tad off-putting
when they both lie about it twice, and ultimately
need to open their mouths to expose the lie.
"CoComelon's" first version of "Johny
Johny Yes Papa" is more true to form,
with JJ playing Johny, getting caught eating
sugar, and lying about it. The father finds it
cute that JJ says he wasn't eating sugar
when he clearly has some in his mouth,
but the cuteness just isn't there when the
parents treat each other like children.
Young viewers clearly don't have too
critical of an outlook toward media yet,
because they seem to be all in on the
many characters of "CoComelon." However,
many parents have to admit being completely
creeped out by the slightly haunting,
almost Chucky-like facial
expressions of these characters.
"I don't believe it. I just don't believe it."
For a little over a year,
Collider contributor Matt Rooney lived
with his brother, his brother's partner,
and their first child. After being exposed to
countless hours of "CoComelon," he reported,
Thanks to films like "The Exorcist,” "The
Shining," "Children of the Corn," and "The
Ring," there is no shortage of horror movies
involving creepy children. At this point,
the concept is basically its own
horror sub-genre. For this reason,
many adults find something terrifying
about "CoComelon"'s uncanny,
lifeless smiles. While it's innocent enough
to keep children from running for the hills,
something about the show's imagery wouldn't feel
out of place in a contemporary horror movie.
When a toddler gets a boo boo, they usually want
no part in the washing and dressing of the wound,
but the parents know an infection could set in
quickly. In looking over the few instances of
first-aid in "CoComelon," it doesn't take
a medical professional to see the issues.
Doctor Mike Varshavski, a Board certified Family
Medicine practitioner and the number one health
and medicine influencer on YouTube, reviewed "The
Boo Boo Song." He noticed that when Cody falls and
scrapes his knee, his mother simply puts a bandage
over it without washing or disinfecting the wound.
Other red flags from "CoComelon"'s depiction
of medical care include putting a bandage on
a stubbed toe and listening to a patient's
lungs from the front instead of the back.
The most egregious mistake of all, though,
is the use of an otoscope — the very pointy
tool used to examine the patient's ear — on
the patient's eye. Doctor Mike warns viewers
to use the very flat ophthalmoscope
for eye inspections, and stating,
"If you do that on a medical
standardized exam, you would fail!"
Additionally, when JJ gets sick in "Sick
Song," his parents care for him. When his
mom sneezes at the end of the video, JJ and his
father laugh. Parents everywhere will tell you
how often they've been sick because of their
kids, and would not laugh along with this.